speaking of
well not speaking of let's take a
tangent girdles and completeness theorem
i'm curious to know what you see as the
applicability or non-applicability of it
with regard to how the brain operates so
someone like penrose or lucas would say
that
it implies that the brain is not purely
computational in the way that we
imagine computation let's say in a
touring sense
because of so and so i'm sure you know
the argument
what do you what do you see as what does
girdles and completeness theorem has
i don't think it has that much relevance
to it to be honest um
i i read i remember reading penrose's
book
the emperor's new mind uh about
well 30 years ago now i think shortly
after it came out just at the beginning
of
when i was just about to go to college
um
waiting for this enlightenment about why
it was going to be relevant
and it's clearly a very
important piece of mathematical
philosophy right
it's telling us that that there are
axioms with any given formal system that
cannot be proven to be true within
that formal system um
and as i understand it was a sort of big
blow against the hilbert program of
trying to bring closure to the
to mathematical explanations uh
and but
quite what that has to say about the
brain
i've never been convinced that it has
that much to say
um and this is partly because
you know i don't think the brain is a
computer
yeah and and so
the fact that okay what do you mean when
you say that because clearly
well again well not clearly really it's
sort of yeah i mean it does get a bit
complicated because
you know firstly quite what it is like
well what quite what exactly is good
altera
saying it seems to be because of course
the
touring class of computation is
something where there is there is
closure
um and
so i guess for me goodall
girdle's theorem
if you apply it to the brain
it may tell you that
the brain is not a computer
um on the reasoning that
there are things that
we can understand to be
true within
a formal system that where proof where a
proof of that
doesn't necessarily exist
um this is going way back because it's
been a long time so i thought of this
thought about this but firstly that
doesn't seem
that surprising because even if the
brain were
a computer a computer of this so we
don't know quite exactly what kind of
computer it is so we don't
quite know what sorts of
true statements should be not
establishable
by the kind of computer that the brain
might happen to be
but i'm basically i'm kind of happy with
the with the idea
that that uh
the brain cannot be is not a
does not operate according to these
principles of logic and that it's not it
doesn't
reach true conclusions about truths by
uh combining these logical operations in
in a particular way
that that good or certain wrestle i mean
goodell's room is a sort of reduction i
think isn't it i mean it's a real
um strong form of logic
uh that's does that put you at odds with
some of your colleagues because as far
as i understand most of them
believe that the brain is some
computational device that could be wrong
could just have a bias set
no i think you're right i think that i
don't know if it sets at odds but but i
but well i mean firstly i don't think it
particularly
the whole point about goodall's theorem
for penrose was this then made a
claim about consciousness yeah and that
was a connection that was to be honest
never very clear to me
and sort of the idea that you know we
consciously experience
things that as being true or false
that we know cannot be proven that way
by a system of logic through goodwill's
theorem so therefore consciousness is
not
uh a property of these kinds of
formal systems again fine
right still might be the case that the
brain does do some information
processing
it still might be the case that that
that it is just
of a you know a constrained or
restricted kind
so you can you can i think you can have
that you can accept that the brain is an
information processing device
but maybe it doesn't have the kind of
class of universality for which good
else theorem becomes
relevant not all computers have to be
universal
and but i do also
worry that people use that language too
loosely when they talk about
the brain it's a very easy thing to say
that the brain processes information
um and that
consciousness is a form of information
processing of some sort that we just
don't quite understand yet